It turns out that, yes, if there have been many bugs in one place,
it is likely that there will be more bugs in the very same place.
This is the more interesting, because all the bugs we see have been fixed,
so you'd assume that over time there would be fewer bugs.
But that's not the case.
With bugs it's like fishing.
You find plenty of bugs in one place one day.
The next day fish will assemble at the same place again,
possibly because fish like the same places again and again,
except that for fish we have a good theory on how the reproduce.
For bugs, we do not.
There is a bit of a hypothesis though.
The assumption is that the same factors that have contributed to bugs in the past
will keep on contributing in the future.
Generally speaking, past fixes and a bit less so past changes
are good predictors for future fixes.